Islamic greetings (may peace and blessing of Allah be upon you) brother and sisters and dear friends
welcome to this video, this video, this video will be very beneficial, where going to talk about something
Ali RA said and sheikh uthaymeen and a few verses
from ibn taymiyyah which can help us understand
what im trying to say here today , now guys having knowledge is something really important
it's what our religion teaches us, to gain knowledge is really important, however some people gain knowledge
for the wrong reasons, and this will not be accepted from Allah, and this will not be accepted from Allah
If your gaining knowledge for other than Allah i's not going to be accepted from you, now some people
it's not about gaining knowledge because when you gain knowledge you have to understanding
implemented etc, now what happens when a lot of people think they are gaining knowledge
but the only thing they are gaining is memorization of passages and information that's what's happening
now a lot of people have knowledge practise it both brothers and sisters but have no hikmah (wisdom)
when you don't have hikmah, you're going to cause damage, how? now if you have the knowledge
and if you have the knowledge and you have no hikmah you cause damage, how do you do that?
Ali RA has said do not tell the people what they are not ready to hear, do you want them to disbelieve
in Allah and his messenger, this is so profound and a beautiful saying. Where going to understand two things
from this, one of them sheikh uthaymin has made more clearer, subhanallah and i read it was really amazing
the first thing is this, that now you have information and let's SUPPOSE and I repeat there is no such hadith like
this and i am giving you guys and example, there is no such haditih like this, im giving you guys an example
I repeat again, ok less SUPPOSE prophet Muhammad SAW (peace be uppon him) said
let's SUPPOSE that a wife has to kiss her husbands feet for 2 hours a day, for example
now I read this information and I'm like 'wow' ok good, now ok I say let me make a youtube video about this
let me tell the sisters they need to know it's knowledge, it's a hadith it needs to be said
ok how could we share this knowledge, I go to sisters, to the married sisters and those who are going
to get married just so you know the prophet said you should kiss your husbands feet 2 hours a day
yeah, now the problem here is this, nobody is saying what you're conveying is haraam, what we're saying
is there is a time and a place ALI RA say do not tell the people what they are not ready to comprehend
do you want them to disbelieve in Allah and his messenger, what do we have to understand from this
if I go to someone and I tell this to the mass public people are going to be 'like what', why will the prophet say this that
it's something they can't understand, they can't grasp this and you telling them that is going to
cause repercussions (they will question things which are not correct) and is going to cause more HARM than GOOD
so that's why there are certain things that should not be said, a person who doesn't have hikmah will go out and tell everyone
me going to couple of people you cause harm, however if you have a platform, goes to anyone brothers and sisters
if you have a platform, I have a platform, me going and saying this on youtube to people is unnecessary
is it needed? do I need to mention this hadith?, NO, it's unnecessary it doesn't need to be said, is it a necessity or is there a problem going on? NO
is it going to cause more harm than good, YES , so it's wrong for me to go and share this information with anyone, any lay man,
somebody who has just accepted islam, somebody who is born muslim maybe, who doesn't
understand or comprehend certain things, its wrong for me to say it, however this is one point, a person with
hikmah will say its unccessary,  I got the information,  I know it, I will keep it to myself, it is only for specific individuals it's not for them
person with hikmah will say this, it will cause more harm than good so let'
s not convey this, however
now sheikh uthaymeen said something profound ' it is therefore an aspect of wisdom in dawah calling those towards Allah
that you should not supprise people with things which they are not able to comprehend rather you should call them in stages
bit by bit until their minds are settled. The sheikh goes further by explaining what Ali RA has said in another aspect
another viewpoint. What I said keep that to aside, this is what sheikh uthaymeen said' this is another form
of causing people to disbelieve in Allah and his messenger, if I go to somebody and say for example
lets suppose there is a brother, hey by the way there is no such hadith, this is only as an example
do you know sister the prophet said that you should kiss your husband feet for 2 hours a day, did you know that ?
if she turns to me and tells me 'you are a liar', Allah and his messenger will never say such a thnig
and I go on hold on a second sister it's authentic, but she persists and says 'your lying', what have I done
I'm telling her it's authentic but she still rejecting it, I'm causing her to say statements of kufr (disbelief)
and she's gonna say Allah and his messenger will never say that, what am I doing this is indirectly
I am causing her to disbelieve by rejecting statements from the messenger. Do you get it?
this is what sheikh uthaymeen is saying is that don't say that, don't say that because the person can't comprehend it
they're are going to say it's a lie this is not true, this cant be the messenger, look at the hikmah
the hikmah of our scholars, wallahi that is why it is so important and one thing it reminds me of is that
when mu'ad ibn jabal was sent to Yemen the prophet Muhmaad SAW, sent him to Yemen and said
call the people to tawhid (oneness of Allah), if they accept that then tell them about the 5 daily prayers
if they accept that then tell them about zakaah and if they accept that etc etc. Why didn't the prophet
say go straight away and tell them to pay zakaah, go to them straight away and tell them to go hajj (pilgrimage),
no, he said first the fundamental thing, tawhid calling them to the oneness of Allah, after if they accept that then..
tell them, thats what sheikh uthaymeen said, bit by bit, till they comprehend and understand, yes
ok, so brothers and sisters one thing I want to say, nobody is saying don't talk about tawhid people are not ready to hear it , no
of course, there are things you have to talk about, but don't speak things which are unnecessary
and I'm going to finish off with this Ibn taymiyaa said when enjoying good and forbiding evil
if the evil is greater than the the good, for example if I say this hadith more harm than good will occur then
dont say it because your going to cause more evil than good. Brothers and sisters that is about it, i just wanted to share that with you
let's be careful in the things that we say, let's not cause people to disbelieve in Allah and is messenger
you will be accountable hold your tongue brothers and sister because your causing harm don't
there is a bit by bit process if you can't hold your tongue study knowledge but don't talk, learn knowledge ,benefit yourself
this is my concern, I hope you guys benefited, may Allah grant everyone of you Jannah, share this with your friends and family, until next time, goodbye.